are you worried about darius hoping your
dreams
go oh
boy i hit him again i'm so sorry
you bounce your head back when my drink
is from your body why do you why is it
so hard to make a head jesus oh my god
you all ready
come on let me go back to that line
about darius cause i can't wait for
another walloping all right here we go
all right uh oh cameron um
is your hand okay
all right um okay uh uh so you you go up
and then and i say darris okay okay
great okay
darius is finally not haunting my dreams
no way i'm i'm out
if it makes you feel any better i cannot
eat gelato either right it doesn't make
me feel better i don't care i am lactose
intolerant right well wow that happens
to uh i think
wow that's not normal whatever that was
i mean that is years old whatever just
i'm gonna you know what i'm gonna go
i can hear you giggling patrick
hold on
[Music]
that's perfectly normal
but that that's what i'm talking about
that is
an
ancient evil whatever that is
you